This week on thug melts.
We own the come up with Emma by Jane
Austin.
Okay.
21 year old Emma Wood houses.
The fine is little banging.
Hi Barry Girl.
Got It all to hell of braids.
High Class Rep and fat stacks thing is
this damn piece.
Want to keep living a single life.
One night she going on about how she
hooked up or governance with the rich
playboy named Mr Westin when her brother
in law nightly roller to the crib.
Imma tell him she's going to play
matchmaker one vinyl time for this holy
roller cat named Ms.
Dot.
Helton.
Later the woodhouse fam throw a banging
party when Emma started conversating
with a sweet little girl named Harriet
Smith.
Now Harry and ain't exactly packing man
brains.
So Emma decide she's going to coach her
to live the high life like she do while
she kicking it with Emma Harry and peep
game at the son of a family of farmers.
Robert Martin and her panties
immediately hit the flow.
Damn,
he fined.
But Emma like,
oh you don't want to mess or no scrub
ass.
Fama girl Emma,
thanks.
She got to hook her up with a real
playboy like Elton.
So Emma,
get her Cuban on in veins looking good
between area in and out.
But when weren't calm that Robert Martin
want to get with Marriott.
Emma like Ah,
you can't be slumming it on no farm your
whole life girl.
When nightly recognize that imma tell
hair.
Are you the dog Robert Martin?
Well he like girl.
You must have lost your mind if you
think Elton care about Harriet.
He only cares about rich bitches.
I mean women.
Matter of fact,
MSL blind,
she don't even recognize that Elton
might be Jonesing for her ass.
One Night Alan start throwing game at
Emma and she all like hold up.
I thought it was hairy it on a rag,
but he like,
oh that bitch only talked to her cause
she tells you what to do and metallic
boy Harry,
it all told about l not one hers,
but she beats through the pain and head
off to visit some homies called the
basises.
Turns out there's a new gal on the
block.
The bates is his knees,
Jane Fairfax.
Now Jane is foxy smart ag of buster sick
flow on the piano forte.
Emma is used to being the bad bitch bits
on the block so she getting all turned
that everybody digging Jane's game
instead of hires specially says Jane
ain't got the facts.
Fact facts are the rap sheet got so Mr
Western son Frank Churchill drop in and
start chopping it up with him or I did
some good laughs.
Frank got a bounce cause it's id sick
but from the lungs of it rather than
might be getting suite on Emma.
Emma like Nah he probably better for
Harry.
Meanwhile Mr.
Allen ended up getting heads to some
rich hot seat that k nobody staying
later.
Frank come back to town but Emma puts
his ass in the friend zone.
They decided to hit the club anyway and
what Harry Rolling Solo on the dance
floor nightly step up this dog freaking
on it a few days later.
Harrier says she's moved on from Allen
the song one way flight.
Emma.
Thank it's that cat frank,
since he got her back when she was
getting mad dog by crew of Gypsies
couple of days ago.
Thank goodness over the next two days.
Frank Star,
dirty Mac and Emma in front of the whole
hood.
Damn Frank.
That ain't nice dog nightly.
Say he going to skip town for a few days
but before he leaves he looked like he
about the kids in Emma's hand but he
pulled out at the last second.
I know that move Emma still gig that he
thought about it though next day phrase
and it takes that long dirt now some now
amma thinking he could stop the bus and
get what?
Harriet but then break Yo south.
Emma get worried that Jane and Frank got
engaged on the loud.
Loud.
What?
What about Harry,
you and this Gibran Brawny been smooth
talking me.
Why thieves in gaze?
Aw Hell Nah.
When news come to Harriet,
she all like girl,
I ain't in the bitch ass.
Chomps like frank.
Anyway,
I got this other dude I don't like hold
up girl.
You're talking about nightly damn
straight.
I'm going to start bugging hard cause
she started realizing that she want to
be when nightly now emma thinking she
should have never taken area out of the
hood.
So nightly come by.
Emma thinking he probably Gone Jab on
about Harry his booty but surprise bitch
nightly say he loved Mary.
Emma like that girl,
you're lost her goddamn mine.
Nightly proposes and Emma saying Hell
Yeah player put a ring on it.
I mean yeah this one,
this one and my son Harry and a lot of
sand,
sorry girl nightly his mom man now but
later she find out Harry,
you're going to marry that farmer boy
and Robert Martin.
Anyway so she ended up getting her freak
nasty on tilt.
So both couples getting married and it's
all good in the hood,
like all fresh jams laid down.
But my girl Jane Austin,
this tax got an ass load to say about
women and society back in the day.
Emma's a choice example of what an
empowered woman or the time looks like.
Whereas most gals had to rely on men.
Fair thing.
Emma don't need nothing from nobody.
She got the money and the power to
control her own life,
both in the crib and in the hood.
Sound's all good,
right?
Set that control ain't all it's cracked
up to be.
Matter of fact,
it just turns her into a miserable
haven.
The real evils indeed of Emma situation
where the power of having rather too
much her own way and the disposition to
think a little too allover itself.
These were the disadvantages which
threatened to Lloyd's or her many
enjoyments.
The danger however was that presence so
on proceed that they did not by any
means grandkids misfortunes with her.
Funny thing is Miley always telling him
what that is,
the duty of fat cats to look out for the
pope folk since they the leaders of the
hood,
but like my girl Jane Austin,
do she just slang an irony up in here,
cause money show is held on make people
act right towards anybody.
Now check I that fuck boy out and sugar
mama.
She just came up in the game and got
paid but still be acting like a fool.
Always acting nasty and saying stupid
shit in front of everybody.
That new money show didn't give her no
class,
but even without slow pockets,
people still acting out.
Elton thank he can get with Emma,
but say Harry,
you're too much of a hood rat and
married,
so it's good for him or the slum it with
you,
but you too.
Good for Harriet.
Fuck that player.
Truth is Austin Hayden or anyone who
obsessed with rank or status,
no matter what your money looked like,
but she throw the most Ceda Emma who
spent her time thinking that people got
to stay in that place and anybody who
tried to better themselves,
it's just clowning.
Just check out what she's saying.
When Elton tried to put a ring on it,
he must know that unfortunate
consequence.
She was greatly his superior.
He must know that the one houses had
been sat up for several generations at
Hartfield.
The younger brands have a very ancient
family and that the alums were nobody
for Emma,
such a hater.
How can they read a tolerate her stank
ass?
Well,
that's when my girl Jane austen's pro
writing skills come into play.
She slanging this technique called free
indirect discourse.
Basically,
the narration is highly close to Emma's
thoughts,
but it also includes some outside
commentary,
Latin,
a step back from her wack ass
perspective so the audience can follow
her motivations but not how to deal with
the shallow bulls.
I put her down,
you feel me?
Thank goodness though Austin don't use
free and direct discourse.
What the more righteous characters like
Miss Westin and nightly since miss w and
k money too legit to quit.
Austin just let their words speak for
themselves.
This is only one emma learn that Harriet
is going to marry the farmer boy that
she recognize all this social status job
don't mean nothing.
You can get rich like Mrs Elton and
still act like a chump are.
You can be a low level hustling like
Robert Martin and still be classy.
Even if you got humble beginnings like
Mr Weston High Society going to treat
you right.
If you act real,
if you show respect,
you're going to get respect straight up.
It don't matter if you got cash or
streets certified status,
it's all how you act.
That's going to get you where you going.
No matter where your family come from or
how much you got in the bank.
You should always focus on how you treat
people.
And if being on the social come up is
the only thing on your mind,
then you best shot yourself son.
Cause you looking in the wrong places
y'all.
That shit ain't gonna make you a better
person.
Only yo actions can do that.
You,
me,
yeah,
catch you out.
And next time I well read Paula's well
both name before you go because we've
got big news this year we've launched an
audio series,
thug notes get lit and each episode I
dive into list of the trailers,
riders,
characters,
plots,
themes and more.
Oh from the world of literature.
Some of you like what's your boy.
Dot.
Sweet does here with thug notes,
check out those get lit.
It's available on itunes and all these
spots you find pocket.
And as always we've got lots more videos
on the way.
So click here to go to our title page.
And if you haven't already,
make sure to subscribe by Your Dad.
Catch on.
Next star players face.